Michael and Bharti you see this beauty
on his right hand they're blinding me
from across the right so which camera do
wanted Nick in your BAE that's Nick
right there there you go
zoom in just give me give me a give me a
fist just keep it right there and point
it to that camera right there there you
go that's why you lift all them weights
right that's why you lift all them what
why that's a weight to lift we see nice
very nice of mr. crab mine let me see
I'll check so it's a good oh you didn't
get this from Putin no I did not our
sport Trump he did give one who Trump
right it is this is this the fourth one
or the fifth one there's five oh this
thing this is truly one of the most
unbelievable pieces of jewelry I've ever
which a hammer am I going right there
Wow you know zoom in on that baby Wow
man oh man that's pretty cool you know
it's funny how they've changed over the
years my first year in the league in 84
we won the Super Bowl and they were they
look like big high school rings you know
right and that you couldn't even wear
them then and now they're just really
they go right back in after yeah they go
right back in where you'd only keep this
you have to keep it in a safe it says we
are all Patriots with an autograph of
Robert Kraft the date of the game
greatest comeback ever
that's what it says inside 283 diamonds
on that baby
that is Wow 28 to 3 never forget
Congrats brother thank you rich
appreciated by put Lambo on her side
the analysts from the ringer and former
executive of the front offices of the
Patriots Browns and Raiders just to name
a few Michael Lombardi good to see you
sir nice to be here rich which is which
is the most impressive team from week
one that you saw
I thought Kansas City did a great job in
the off season of really game planning
and and get into situations I think when
you just look at the touchdown pass to
Tyreke Hill they got into a formation
they made the Patriots adjust to a
coverage that they really didn't want to
be in and they threw it I thought Andy
did a great job of game planning I
thought the Raiders were unique in the
first week I thought the Raiders playing
his own defense more than they ever have
before
they've always been a man to man and I
think it caught Tennessee by surprise
they played zone and they played it well
sometimes when man teams try to play
zone they don't play it as effectively
and I thought the Raiders showed some
diversity in their portfolio in terms of
their defense I think it's going to help
them down the stretch and I thought
Marshawn Lynch was really the best
defender they have so so that's a great
way because they closed it out with him
he was close he is truly and I thought
he would be Mariano Rivera and he is
Mariano Rivera I mean he's hard to
tackle and a little bit like what
Jacksonville has going to when they run
for net and they run ivory at the same
time you know it's it's two really angry
runners coming at you and both of them
for net more then most people thought
coming out in the draft was very
effective in the passing game so I think
that gives you a dynamic and in the
fourth quarter in the heat humidity
those guys are hard to tackle there
really are hard to tackle and I think
you could see the difference in
Seattle's team with Eddie Lacy not being
that same powerful explosive back that
they missed with Marshawn Lynch so you
just gave a lot of stuff for me to chew
on so I'm gonna I'm gonna try and start
from the beginning what does Belichick
take from that Thursday night game
knowing him and this organization as
well as you do well they you know they
did things that they typically don't do
they gave up big plays which is the one
of the violations they never set the
edge of the defense which is one of the
Belichick Ian rules of football we got
to set the edge let's set the edge where
we force the ball back inside they got
around the corner too easily and they
didn't convert third and short you know
I often say that the secret marcus
aurelius says the secret to all victory
lies in the organization of the
non-obvious well converting third and
one may seem obvious but you got to have
right plays to run at the right time
well they did
convert four thin ones and it looks with
Brady why which which is because they
were jumped in the a gap and so they
went a little wider and and and Barry
made a great play and I think that when
you look at that they they got beat at
their own game
I mean they practice that stuff a lot
and credit the Chiefs the Chiefs did a
great job of defending them that she
they worked the ball down the field and
if for a Belichick team to be so poor in
the red zone offensively and defensively
I think that's gonna give them a lot I
think this will be a challenge this week
yeah this isn't gonna get turned around
overnight at in New England like right
all of a sudden you know Bell check will
tell a team often you know there's no
magic pill we can take to turn this
around it takes hard work and it's just
not gonna happen in a week so knowing
the self scouting side of Belichick as
well as you do again what do you think
in the most private moment that maybe
he's not sharing with anybody he's like
I don't know if I'll be able to fix that
well I think I I think the thing he's
got a really employers team to do we you
know people want him to sign some player
from the outside got to get the players
that he has better allen branch has to
play to a level that he played last year
he didn't play to that in the first game
he's capable of it but he didn't and I
think a lot of the other guys have to
play better Dante Hightower got hurt in
the game but there's a lot of guys that
have to improve their play and they have
to come together that's why I think what
you when you see with most teams is you
have to start over again every season is
a new season and they have to come
together and September is part of
preseason it truly is I know you've said
that so which teams do you think in week
one had those preseason Blues to start
the season that you think are gonna be
okay when it's all said well I think
likes like Baltimore's offense wasn't
very effective I know Joe Flacco
complained about he wished he would have
thrown more than 17 passes their office
but their defense was ready to go if
Baltimore's offense gets going in
through the month of September because
Flacco didn't have any preseason at all
right they can really be a threat to the
Pittsburgh Steelers in the north there's
no question in my mind they have the
defense to better speed wise so I think
that team but they won and they won but
you know but Seattle for example Seattle
kind of knows who they are and maybe
Eddie Lacy is and what they hoped he
would be in terms of his quickness and
explosion I think the Saints are another
team they have those three running backs
everybody talks about AP the cameras
were focused on him so much when you
know we have a saying and scouting then
as then now is now and so you have to be
able to play now to the level that you
played before or else it's just over and
so ap does he fit into that offense and
I think the other thing is the back will
determine for the Saints what they're
going to do
so if chimera is in the game that's one
thing if if engrams in a game it's
another thing it's the same thing for
the New York Football Giants when
engrams in the game if he lines up on
the line of scrimmage a tight end
that's probably gonna be a pass if he
lines up in the backfield there could be
a motion and he's gonna move around
because people will now after a weak one
they see wait a man and doesn't block
anybody okay so he's really not a tight
end he's a wide receiver so they start
classifying people and that's when
you'll see the evolution of the game's
changing a little bit Michael Lombardi
the ringer here in the Rich Eisen show
so you think Seattle's gonna be fine
you know I think ci wants to fix their
offensive line I think their defense is
really good I think their defense got
tired you know it's a little bit like
the Giants defense that was really good
the other night but it's hard to play
double headers in the NFL it's really
hard to play a double they play double
header see how the offense they're on
the field all the time they couldn't
convert you know you're playing double
headers it's tough you get tired and
especially in the heat and humidity and
look let's face it the preseason
these guys didn't play four quarters so
you're a little bit like you're not
ready to play all the time so you have
to go out there and compete and I think
that that they'll get better I think the
Giants offensively have work to do cuz
everybody says oh oh Del's coming back
it'll be fine they averaged 19 points
here last year with odo like why is this
gonna get fine there's a there's an
inherent problem with the Giants system
so when when they finally got past the
35 yard line yeah offensively their own
35-yard line offensively on on a pass
play and they cut to Ben McAdoo and he
put a checkmark at the top of his play
see what what walk me through what what
what did that check mark mean when he he
basically changed the special on the
Cheesecake man I am so disappointed in
Ben he changed this place sheet like I
looked so forward to seeing him with
that place he's a huge thing he's
incredible now how about with no time on
the clock he's still checking things on
this place she like I mean I got exactly
I don't know I don't know what does that
mean I don't know I can't answer it look
I know this football football is a game
of execution and footballs a game of pad
level
and playing with toughness and the
Giants offensively can't seem to do that
and they haven't done it since he's been
the head coach I mean that's the reality
right now now can it turn around I don't
know I mean Eli has not played or thrown
the ball down the field effectively that
he has to do whether Odell's in the game
or not
I mean Brandon Marshall I tweeted this
the other day he is in the witness
protection program was he like big
[ __ ]' dizzy in Puerto Rico
yeah I wasn't sure where he was Sopranos
reference you know I like where is he
you guys decide where is he I don't know
you know like Brandon Marshall didn't
look comfortable he didn't look
comfortable in the offense he never got
lined up right all the time so it was a
little difficult so you think the lines
have a shot to go into MetLife from
MetLife opener and I know Kevin Clark
and I just did a bunch of videos for the
ringer they'll be up this tomorrow he's
a terrific by the way we've had him on
the show he's outstanding and so Kevin
and I have this thing where we call make
the case and then we also have a segment
called apologies in advance where we
apologize to people that were going to
insult just a little bit just a little
bit and then and Detroit's one of those
that I I just don't buy Detroit I
thought it was a great win for them
I'm just not behind them I think I think
Arizona was an overrated team coming in
I thought carson palmer we've talked
about it on this show was an older
player that was declining last year that
gave indications that perhaps he wasn't
going to be the carson palmer of 15 and
so that was a great win for Detroit but
I just don't know if Detroit has enough
I think Detroit's will have a tough time
moving the ball against that New York
Giants defense and they won't play a
doubleheader the Giants defense I want
to play I want to take a 60-second break
right here come back talk about the
Colts you said the Rams
prior to the season would be a team that
would be tanking for one with the loss
and back some campus here by the middle
of the season I'm wondering what you
thought of the Rams first week with
Shawne McVeigh and so much more with
Michael and Bharti 844 200 for Rich's
the number to dial we've also got Derek
Fisher in studio our three back in a
minute with Lambeau
I'm occults I don't put Andrew Luck in
it and behind that offensive line at all
that said maybe it was just week one
they were playing to me a triple header
because of the way Scott tolsey looked
yeah and so what do the Colts do you
know I'm Chris Ballard I think you have
to change the culture of the
organization and it starts with
rebuilding both offensive and defensive
line and this is a monumental task
you're faced with and I think Andrew
Luck's health should be the first and
first matter of importance you can't put
it back on the field unless you can
protect them and you can scheme wise
protect them I mean it can't be seven
step drops I mean they just don't have
any symmetry they have these little
receivers they need to get them the ball
down the field they really you know the
line can't protect it's a little
problematic what they do and then
defensively look I you know the Rams
played really well I thought they did a
great job game planning for Jared Goff
but that Colt defense without Vontae
Davis they just don't have enough blue
chip players to make any plays and they
couldn't that day are you hearing
anything about luck warning out of Indy
I don't you know look if you know
anything about Andrew Luck Andrew Luck's
mentality is I think he thinks he can
cure cancer and have anything he's gonna
take every challenge yeah to the finest
III don't I just don't think it's in his
personality I mean there's everybody's
gonna have certain rumors but I always
go back to a person's personality and
who their habits are and their trade and
I think this is a kind of kid that
really believes in the old Catholic
school stick-to-itiveness and and I
think he is truly wants to win there and
I mean look they've gotten paid a lot of
money and I'm gonna would probably be
really difficult to even try to trade
him I think it would be fascinating if
the Colts actually ended up with the
first pick in the draft in this
quarterback draft that Bruce was talking
about and you is wouldn't that be
hilarious if they had that and then they
could really fix their team well they
could definitely and perhaps maybe
that's you know the conspiracy theorist
to me maybe that's why they're playing
Scott tolsey because I can't imagine
they watch practice and think he gives
him any sense of confidence that he can
be theirs
he can win games for well they can't put
him out there this week against no I
don't think they could I think that I
think I think chuck would lose the
locker room at that point I mean at some
point the players I mean you got Frank
Gore who's a great player who wants to
win he competes at everything he does
whether it's you know tennis or anything
and he wants to win and the seasons too
early to give up on it now so maybe
Jacobi Brissette can come in there
do some things that they need to do
they're playing at home which helps
it'll help their defense a lot the crowd
noise always has helped their defense so
that's what they're gonna need so um you
said before the season because I read
everything that you write on the ringer
as well okay that three teams that will
be tanking by midseason for Rosie Nord
Arnold and you mentioned the Jets which
I think they've already started that
process the Jets need a quarterback I
think there's no doubt okay you know
then you mentioned the Browns yep so I
don't think Kaiser is is going to be
real this is I think the Browns are in a
really tough spot because they're gonna
have to correctly evaluate Kaiser
correctly and that's gonna be hard to me
why did you repeat that word because
they could you could fall have false
hope you could think oh we got our
quarterback and then realize we just
passed on Sam Rosen or Josh Rosen or we
just passed on Lamar jet we just passed
on a better player they got it correctly
that's a hard place to be in the easiest
place to be is he can't play or he can
play right that's easy it's that middle
place that you'd never want to be in and
any decision I think that's where the
Browns are gonna be headed they have to
make it I thought Kaiser young player
held the ball too long it didn't flow
off his hand as well as you like thought
his toughness was good as accuracy was
all over we're gonna need more games
before you just write them off my
instincts would tell me that it you know
he's not gonna be as good as some of
these guys are coming out and then the
other team you said were the Rams yeah
you know and I and I I think look III
admit the Rams played well owns I think
Jared Goff played really well but I
think Jared Goff is a true
seven-on-seven quarterback and I think
when the game speeds up I think it
becomes problematic for him and the game
never speed it up if he can play and
stand back there and use the skills and
throw the ball in rhythm I thought Sean
McVeigh they did a great job I think
whatever you see a team that does a lot
of motion and direct like when they
faked the handoff and the and the
receiver comes to back in motion they're
trying what they're trying to do it's
called separate the defense plays so
they want to separate the defense so the
defense reacts so it's easy for the
quarterback to make the throw and they
did a really good job of running a lot
of separation defense throws and I think
he did a good job of making the place
now this week when the game speeds up
against the Redskins and they start
heating them up a little bit can he
process it quick enough I just don't see
that in his game yet and
what the Redskins also we're gonna know
defensively what what's coming they're
all yeah I mean one thing about this
game the Redskins playing the the Rams
is they both practiced against each
other without practicing against each
other I mean every day they went to ot a
days they saw the Rams offense in
Washington and the Rams saw the
Washington offense in in Los Angeles so
they'll be well accustomed to and I
think this game will be what team makes
slight adjustments within their scheme
to try to confuse them going to try to
do that would you say the Chiefs and
Eagles game this week absolutely the
same thing I think I think the hit on I
took a lot of lot of heat this week from
tilde I don't know if I can even go back
to my home in New Jersey oh because the
Doug Peterson and I think that the
Eagles in a Pierson has always just
taken the Kansas City offense and just
run it in Philadelphia the challenge is
gonna be can he run it now against the
Kansas City defense but that's a little
bit like another squad game as well who
do you think has the advantage just read
because he's the older have agreed I
think they have the advantage clearly
have the advantage in Jack in Kansas
City because the crowd loose it's so
hard to play in there I think whence
whose really becoming Ben Roethlisberger
like in terms of hard to get him on the
ground and he's hard and and his
movement creates plays I mean people say
look the Eagles won you do bad-mouth
Peterson well the play that Winston made
a touchdown throw that's not drawn up
that's whence this being a really good
player and take your hat off the wince I
think that'll be a challenge to do that
on the road again in a loud stadium
against a good defense what happens on
Sunday night between Green Bay and
Atlanta do you think you know I was
really impressed with green based
defensive front Kenny Clark played
really well I think Mike Daniels has
been it has been close to being a blue
chip player for a long time I think
that's gonna be a challenge for them new
stadium I'm not mad Ryan played well
against the Bears
I think this Packer team is a much
better complete team than they've been I
thought the Packers have a have a have a
much better complete team I think they
can probably beat the Falcons but I
think the Falcons look there I said this
summer they're gonna be better on
defense I thought they were against the
Bears so Michael and Barty I know you
because you love pop culture references
again that's what makes you perfect for
the ringer is Bill O'Brien the Keyser
söze
of quarterback gurus like it that you
just everybody thinks he's out there as
a quarterback guru and and he just
doesn't exist you know it's it's what I
call the Emeril Lagasse problem so you
know if you and I want to go
and open up a restaurant right and let's
go steal all of Emeril Lagasse's recipes
and we'll go open it up and we'll cook
it good but we really don't know those
recipes very well so we'll be out of
business in about two weeks because
nobody will be eating any of our food
even though we're cooking Emeril's food
so you can't steal somebody's offense
and I think Bill's trying to run that
New England offense down in Houston and
I think he's running into that
bankruptcy Chris they're gonna be you
know the diner's closed here because he
can't quite get it and I think this is
weak if he goes with Watson which I
think he will he's got to run an offense
that's tailored to Watson quarterbacks
are like baseball stadiums you've got to
build your offense around what they can
do they just not all of them can do
everything and not all of them are Tom
Brady and I think that you know when you
watch the Texans play if it's single
high they throw the ball outside if it's
too deep they run the ball they're
pretty basic and what they do and I
think they have to become a little bit
more diversified but look all that being
said about Bill O'Brien I think the
problem is the offensive line if you
don't block for anybody and they didn't
block last week I don't care who you are
you can't win so then they did he puts
he puts Watson in there because he moves
around better than Savage I think he
gave him a chance I think they needed to
get some lift I mean didn't nobody
thought that they were gonna you know be
down at the half that they were and look
let's face it I'm critical of Blake - I
call on Blake tannic Blake bortles but
tannic the reality here is is that they
didn't even play with a quarterback in
their game rich when you watch the
Houston when Jacksonville game they won
that game because ivory because for net
they made place he made a couple throws
in the game but for the most part I
thought Doug Marrone and his staff did a
great job they said you know what we're
gonna basically run the way we're gonna
play the way we play and Kevin Clarke
and I were talking about this yesterday
so they kind of like they were like
Princeton they ran the Princeton offense
and if you can't stop but they're gonna
win but if you stop it they don't have
another way to go I thought that's what
Jacksonville did a good job ask him the
poll question Christopher go for it yeah
Michael what you want to know team is
the biggest smoke screen what for gays
you use it for gays II freaking lombo
biggest the biggest for gays you want to
know Bill's Jags Rams Ravens what do you
think ah I would say the jacks because I
don't think that Jags are gonna be able
to win play him without a quarterback I
let Blake tan light an ik well because
it's like being on the Titanic I mean
he's going I mean look you can't play
quarterbacks going down the way he does
it it's just not fair
people say you're too harsh on them look
I'm harsh on the reality that
Jacksonville won't admit that they need
a quarterback I mean that's the you know
look I know for a fact in their
interviews with people they barely
brought up the conversation about Blake
bortles until the last five minutes of
the interview because I don't think they
wanted to hear the answer from coach
from morones of the world and from the
coaches that they interviewed yeah I
don't think they wanted to hear the
answer I think I think the answer is
they have to manage Blake and they did a
great job of rich don't take anything
away but that formula that Princeton
formula of winning in the NFL doesn't
exist
what did where does that say the Jaguar
still leading the poll right now you
influence the vote rich a bit 42%
Jacksonville 2726 for the Rams and only
five for the rich and just to bring it
all full circle I mean we'll see what
the Dolphins look like out here against
the Chargers who I thought acquitted
themselves very well on that Monday
night game despite falling down as much
as they did but the two Melvins are
terrific Gordon and Ingram and Phillip
is still Phillip red-ass is good look I
guess we're disappointed me about the
Chargers is when you play Denver in
Denver you want to stay out of third
down you have to make the game a
Canadian game you got to be a CFL team
when you could play in Denver because
what Hass is well you can't make it a 50
pass game no you can't make it a 50 pass
game but you've got to make it so that
you're not in third and long all the
time and San Diego that's almost like
how they were calling the game they were
third and long and they didn't give
Rivers a real chance I think if they
throw it better and they'll do it
against Miami I think this will be a
good game all right and Dallas will do a
much better job staying out of third
down in Denver this but you know Dallas
Dallas is so good in third down though
they're remarkable they thrive some
teams thrive on it
they were good last year on third down
and they can be but you again you're
right you go in there with the crowd
noise and Von Miller coming off the edge
and and those other guys it's tough well
again to bring it all full circle you
take a look at the AFC East Patriots are
gonna win that regardless of how poorly
they looked on Thursday night that said
the thing that I took out of Thursday
night's loss from New England is that
every single time that they went to the
Super Bowl and got a ring like the one
that's on your right hand that you've
been wearing throughout this entire
interview they've had a bye week I don't
know if that's a bye week team certainly
having a tie break now down against a
team that might just be in Kansas City
they've got the Raiders in Mexico City
than analysts
the line and a novela check gets better
and everybody does their job I just
don't know they might have to play four
playoff games to win another ring you
know and look let's face it let's say
you know this is we haven't talked about
this but all the older quarterbacks
didn't play well this weekend
I mean the guys have had some a John
matam did not play well I think he'd be
the first to tell you didn't play well
Carson Carson didn't play well none of
these guys played well as they got older
so maybe it's taken a little longer
we'll have to see I would suspect Tom
will play a lot better but look this
game against New Orleans no give me putt
now I mean New Orleans plays much better
at home the crowd noises in their favor
it helps their defense it helps their
pass rush and look Drew Brees will move
the ball on the on that on that Patriot
defense all right Lambo thanks red you
know actually stick around for just one
more segment I know you're like talking
other sports to will shout the hour with
Michael and barding and then when we
come back we'll keep an eye on what's
going on in Cleveland with the Indians
going for their 21st consecutive
baseball win and an old gen stat that's
coming your way based on that 20 game
win streak is it it's currently
constituted that's all coming up next
here on the Rich Eisen show
Francisco Lindor becomes just the third
switch hitting shortstop with 30 home
runs in a season in Major League
Baseball history Jose Valentin did it in
2004 and the last one to do it was Jimmy
Rollins for four Lambos Phillies back in
2007 that's amazing and that great for
Cleveland I mean they're they're up four
to one right now in what inning is it
guys over there you got that fourth
inning top five and Brad Ausmus has
already been given the gate he's out
they threw him out of the game it looks
like they're gonna get their 21st
consecutive win it is unbelievable and
that brings up an old gents stat here
brought to you by our friends at TrueCar
yeah we're about the old gen stats here
on the show lombo not new gen stats oh
yeah
and it's brought to you by true car you
can find out what other people in your
area paid for the same car you're
looking for and on average save over
3,000 dollars off MSRP whether you're
looking for a new or used car visit true
car to enjoy a more confident car buying
experience the Cleveland Indians in the
20 games span they've won every single
game 15 just the fifth team to have a
100 plus run differential in a 20-game
spent in Major League Baseball history
last team to do it the 1939 New York
Yankees before that the 1938 New York
Senators before that the 1933 Wow New
York Yankees pardon me 1933 Washington
Senators before that and before that the
1904 New York Giants that's it but
that's not your old gen Stan that is not
your old gen stead ready for the old gen
Stan I'm gonna go deeper the 20 game
wins the 20 game win streak that the
current Cleveland Indians had matched
the entire wind total for the 19th the
1899 Cleveland spiders had just 20 wins
I have to see that logo well actually in
terms of we don't have the logo but del
Teufel I do yes we had the rallying cry
that they would play in Stadium back in
1899 this is a Rich Eisen show old gents
that's exclusive of the Cleveland
spiders go for it
I thought you said it was I was all
right spider okay all right fine yellow
I thought you said you were all right
there you go anytime you can work them
in you have an out alright resting man
spider the spiders were not alright
they weren't laughing at him that's your
old gents tat here in the Richardson
change o chance tax one game you got to
watch this week what is it gonna be
Lumbo if you could choose only one game
on the NFL I think that'll be the
interesting New Orleans New England game
because one of those teams gonna be
going to incredible right one of those
are gonna be owing to and it's you know
and if it's and then New England place
Thursday night against Houston so I
think that would be a great game I think
I think Green Bay Atlanta I think look
this weekend is great about adjustments
and figuring out what your team is and
you'll see the coaches shine and see
which of these guys make it I think the
feeling Kansas it'll be a fun game yeah
and then at the own one vs. own one is
Texans vs. Cincinnati as well tonight
since he's in a tough spot since he's
since he's my man Andy Dalton the 2020
quarterback he's going to figure out how
to not throw the interception again and
JJ Watts coming to town thank you thank
you we'll see you next Wednesday
check out Lambeau on the ringer calm and
on Twitter axe em Lombardi NFL very good
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like that
video be sure to download our app don't
have any memory on your phone let's
start to delete some of those slow-mo
videos you have and you know which ones
I'm talking about